voici l'un des premiers châteaux
classiques français avec une symétrie
parfaite bienvenue à Moulinsart non nous
sommes à Cheverny et c'est un décor qui
a séduit à Hergé même si le père de
Tintin n'est jamais venu ici on peut
même dire que moulassar est plus
Cheverny que ce vernis aujourd'hui si on
regarde le Peron l'entrée ici ça c'est
le grand oncle du marquis qui de là
restaurer réaménagé on va dire à la fin
des années 30 l'escalier des aventures
de Tintin c'est l'escalier originel
beaucoup plus fidèle à Cheverny que ce
que l'on peut voir aujourd'hui allez
venez à vous là ça venez venez venez
venez venez
aider l'entrée le grand escalier est un
élément emblématique le visiteur pour
avoir la fameuse marche cassée qui fait
chuter le capitaine Haddock dans les
bijoux de la Castafiore à l'étage la
chambre du roi et la salle des gardes
plongent les touristes au cœur des
aventures du reporter
nous sommes la salle d'armes ou la salle
des Gardes du du château de Cheverny qui
était aussi la finalement la salle de
marine du capitaine Haddock la première
BD en fait dans laquelle apparaît le
château de Moulinsart dans les aventures
de Tintin
c'est le trésor de Rackham le Rouge
c'est la première vue que l'on a de du
château
comme le Journal de Tintin le musée
attire petit et grands de 7 à 77 ans et
400 000 visiteurs chaque année viennent
s'immerger dans leur souvenir
[Musique]
je trouve que la scénographie enfin la
musique plus exactement et très bien
faite parce que là on a vraiment
l'impression de pénétrer plus avant dans
le dans l'univers de Tintin mon père
avait tout à collection et du coup ça
fait partie des premières bandes
dessinées que j'ai j'ai connu enfant
alors vous aussi pour retomber en
enfance venez pousser les portes de
Moulinsart